[Music]
Joker
so Joker's directed by Todd Phillips
starts walking Phoenix I feel like we
all know that by now
this was my number one anticipated movie
of this entire year tried to go in with
no expectations but a huge Joker fan I
can only do so much and what this movie
is is the story of a man who just gets
beat down in life and becomes the comic
book villain Joker and I've said it
before and I guess I'll say it here for
people who haven't seen my videos
talking about it I was really skeptical
about a standalone joke removing them
and Joaquin Phoenix came on I was like
alright he's picky with his scripts I
feel like he saw something special that
he could bring to this and after seeing
Joker
yo that is absolutely positively the
case I feel like I'm gonna talk a lot
about Joaquin Phoenix in this review
because the entire movie is from his
perspective I can't think of a scene in
the movie that he's not in it is his
movie
Joaquin Phoenix carries this entire
movie on his shoulders and never buckles
under the weight of that he thrives he
doesn't buckle and he thrives under the
weight and pressure of portraying the
most iconic comic book villain of all
time he's so good I heard he researched
mental illness that disorder were you
laughs when you're nervous I didn't know
that and then I said something about his
laughs and no he's not emulating the
laughs he just uncontrollably laughs and
I need to stress this this isn't a joker
movie I mean it's titled Joker but if
you're going into this movie like
alright we're gonna see the Joker wreck
some [ __ ] it's a bit more of a slow burn
than that you're getting a character
movie this movie should be called Arthur
like I saw a comment in the comment
section of one of my videos about this
movie one of the trailer videos like oh
I can't I hope there's a lot of action
or something like that I was like that
is gonna be one disappointed person it's
not an action movie and the journey of
Arthur it's not just like oh he's Arthur
flack he's just like dumpy kind of sad
guy and then one day he's the Joker when
he does done the makeup and we saw that
in the trailer otherwise I wouldn't
really talk about it I'm not gonna talk
about it too much but he does carry
himself so differently and it's so
different from where he started that's
one of those it's just a series of
subtle changes a series it is it's true
evolution it's not one big leap it's
like change change change change change
change change change change
well while we're different than where we
start [ __ ] [ __ ] how did we get here it's
just like the movie does such a good job
at taking you on that journey and you by
the journey and it's undeniably a
tragedy or is it a comedy it's so
grounded in reality I almost like is it
a comic book movie graphic novel movie
sure its semantics at that point in
comic books have had some really deep
character arcs absolutely like this is
that Joker gives movie fans and movie
goers the ability to see what comic book
fans have seen for years and I'm glad
I'm glad this movie exists for that
we've hit the next level and since this
movie is 100% Arthur flex movie it is
Joaquin Phoenix is moving I feel like
every other character is in the
background there a support character of
some sort but when this stands out to me
was DeNiro
like DeNiro could have phoned it in just
gotten his paycheck we're like all right
I'm gonna be Robert DeNiro just I'm in
two scenes in the movie let's just do it
and go
but when DeNiro comes out on his show
and you know the bands playing the
bailiff and like he points at the band
like Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam alright we got
a good show tonight like he acts
absolutely like a talk-show host it's
for some reason dinero stands out in
this movie as minimal as his role is and
if you're one of those people that's
like I don't want to see a joker origin
story no don't give me that I'm really
stressed give this movie a shot the
movies it's more nuanced it peels back
the layers in a way where you walk away
completely satisfied it's like this
movie it answers the nearly 80 year old
question what made that guy snap what
made him such a monster I know we've
gotten Killing Joke but this is so much
more of a deep dive I will say yes
sometimes the movie is uncomfortable but
that's because it feels so real it
doesn't feel like a comic book villain
you're not there watching oh hi or Joker
gonna get dipped in acid or even dipped
in societies all right he's gonna put on
the makeup and then commit some crime
the entire time you're rooting for him
to not snap like that I didn't expect
that as a Joker that was like alright
let's snap and get to the real [ __ ] but
you're actually pulling for him to not
do that and you actually feel bad for
him so the fact that there are people
out there who feel like this movie is
uncomfortable
good job movie for doing your job in the
end there were a few things I wanted
from Joker and Joker delivered on them I
thought Joaquin Phoenix was great he
carried this movie perfectly Oscar
nomination I think so it's kind of funny
it's like if you take on the job
cooker and do it well and bring your own
thing to it you could get an Oscar
nomination out of it which just shows it
shows why the Joker is so popular
because he just he has those layers that
were just begging to be peeled back this
movie peeled them back perfectly I only
got one more thing to say about Joker
and that is Joker is awesome tacular
[Applause]
[Music]
Todd Phillips is ready to take on deeper
themes I guess and there's so much more
I want to talk about with Joker and know
this reviews a bit vague so spoiler talk
gonna happen this weekend it has to so
keep an eye out for that
so since I'm going to assume I'm not the
last person on earth to have seen Joker
I'm going to assume you have not seen
Joker yet what other Batman villain
origin story would you be cool with and
who would you cast as them whoever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]